[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat et place ce matin à
l'audition du responsable des affaires
publiques de facebook france
anton maria battesti qui a été
auditionné la semaine dernière dans le
cadre des travaux de la commission d'
enquête sur la souveraineté numérique
cette commission d'enquêté présidée par
le sénateur socialiste franck montaugé
ce dernier a d'ailleurs ouvert
l'audition avec une question franche
limite une attaque
cette question c'est est ce que facebook
veut supplanter et les états au coeur de
la polémique le fait que facebook va
créer sa propre monnaie
libre à une crypte monnaie qui concentre
les critiques critique des banques
critiquent aussi des états qui craignent
que cette monnaie n'offrent pas
suffisamment de garanties en matière de
régulation également qu'elles ne
correspondent pas aux standards des
banques aussi qu'elle puisse poser des
problèmes en matière de lutte contre le
blanchiment d'argent
notez aussi et bien que facebook veut
créer sa propre cour suprême
indépendante
voilà encore de quoi créer des craintes
chez les états face à toutes ces
critiques
anton maria battesti a répondu que
facebook n'était qu'une entreprise
offrant un service un simple réseau
social
notez également que le responsable des
affaires publiques de facebook france a
répondu sur la question de la protection
des données en disant avoir
particulièrement fait des efforts pour
contrôler la protection des données
retour donc à cette audition qui s'est
tenue la semaine dernière au sénat
je tiendrai un propos préliminaires pour
simplement présenter l'entreprise en
france je pense que cela vous
intéressera évidemment je reprenais très
contraints par le temps donc fait très
exactement conditionne vous plaît
j'avais déjà dit vous attend sur les
questions il y en aura d'autres je le
précise du rapporteur anthony par legs
ici présents dans une page donc je vais
simplement préciser le chiffre pour la
france 36 millions d'utilisateurs en
france qui utilisent notre service
facebook au moins une fois par mois à
peu près 200 salariés dans notre bureau
basé à paris et je tiens aussi à
préciser que notre laboratoire
d'intelligence artificielle qui a ouvert
il ya quelques années est un
investissement stratégique que nous
avons fait en france et en europe c'est
le seul laboratoire d'intelligence
artificielle
qui existent en dehors des états unis
qui est très intégrée avec l'écosystème
de la recherche française
nous avons aussi une présence avec le
start au garage au sein de stations f
et enfin nous nous investissons dans des
formations et diverses causes sociétales
soit vers les formations de compétence
au numérique soit via la création en
france d'un fonds pour le civisme en
ligne d'un million d'euros l'année
dernière qui est aussi une création de
facebook france donc je vais
immédiatement répondre au point que vous
avez soulevé en aucun cas facebook
essaye de supplanter les états je
voudrais juste rappeler que facebook est
un réseau social sur lequel des
personnes viennent échanger avec leurs
familles défendre des causes qui leur
tiennent à coeur
s'associer via des groupes facebook pour
aussi défendre les causes qui leur
tiennent à coeur
mais c'est un réseau social multi
facettes qui a vocation à avoir de
nouveaux produits
je pense à marquer deux flèches je pense
au développement de la messagerie on y
reviendra etc etc
et c'est une entreprise qui fournit un
service de l'internet une entreprise qui
s'est beaucoup développée ces dernières
années avec l'acquisition aussi de vous
l'avez mentionné de whatsapp et
d'instagram et ctu une entreprise une
entreprise internationale une entreprise
multinationale et c'est une entreprise
pour autant est ce qu'une entreprise n'a
pas vocation à avoir une responsabilité
sociétale et évidemment et je vais venir
je vais venir tout de suite sur la
question de ses petit chèque vous l'avez
mentionné comme un élément régalien je
n'irai peut-être pas jusque là mais en
tout cas c'est un événement qui rend
service à la société
il a été pour la première fois activée
pour des grisons de terrorisme en france
au mois de novembre 2016 lors des
attentats du bataclan je crois que il ya
eu un consensus à l'époque pour dire que
nous avions bien fait s'est jamais senti
à la jeunesse a permis à beaucoup de
personnes de se signaler en sécurité
dans une situation de crise et cela a
tellement je pense était intéressant
pour l'état que l'état lui-même est venu
à nous
il y as je crois à peu près un an quand
le ministère l'intérieur a décidé
d'arrêter sa propre solution dite sip
c'est le ministère de l'intérieur qui
venu pour entrer en partenariat avec
nous et pour voir comment une synergie
pragmatique et intelligente pouvait se
construire
évidemment entre les services de l'état
et un service privé pour rendre service
à la population ce que nous avons fait
sans aucune hésitation
est ce que je rappelle aussi qu'il ne
coûte absolument pas un euro aux
contribuables pourquoi je précise ça
parce que quand la question s'est posée
de savoir pour le sms les services du
ministère de l'intérieur - indiqué que
les opérateurs souhaité faire payer ce
type de solutions donc je mets un point
d'honneur ici a précisé que nous avons
pris nos responsabilités et nous le
faisons de la manière la plus directe
possible pour ce qui est de l'identité
numérique
on ne reviendra si vous êtes question je
pense sur les données personnelles
s'agit pas là d'être une identité
officielle comme pourrait l'être france
connect
là aussi c'est une facilités offertes
par le service quand vous êtes déjà
inscrit sur notre service facebook
d'autres plateformes derrière offrent ce
type de service vous pouvez utiliser
votre login facebook pardon pour
l'anglais qui vous permet d'utiliser des
jeux ou d'autres types d'applications ou
d'autres sites web sans que vous ayez à
recréer un profil au sein au sein de ses
sites
c'est quelque chose qui a
considérablement évolué depuis plusieurs
années puisque nous avons augmenté et je
pense que vous me parlez de cambridge
analytique 1 pendant cette heure donc je
préfère mettre les pieds dans le plat
nous avons considérablement augmenter
tous les contrôles qui permettent aux
utilisateurs de ne pas partager les
données qu'ils ne souhaitent pas
partager avec des tiers il y a aussi des
audits qui sont conduits à posteriori et
une fine et si vous n'avez pas utilisé
un site ou une application via le
facebook claudine pendant à peu près 100
jours c'est de l'application question
n'a plus le droit d'utiliser vos données
donc on y reviendra peut-être mais en
tout cas s'agit pas d'une identité
officielle il s'agit simplement d'un
service mais rentrons sur les deux
sujets dont je sais qu'il suscite
aujourd'hui énormément d'intérêt si on
prend un
une vision un peu plus large de
l'évolution de l'internet ces trente
dernières années il est devenu
incroyablement facile pour chacune et
chacun d'envoyer une photo en claquant
des doigts à quiconque dans le monde
d'envoyer des messages envoyés des
données et d'envoyer des fichiers etc
c'est ce qui a conduit au cheminement de
l'objet ali brax mais décrire dans
quelques secondes
comme l'a expliqué david marcus sait
mais comment se fait-il avec tous ces
progrès on est encore autant de
difficultés pour transférer de l'argent
d'un point a à un point b
à l'heure de l'économie mondialisée de
services mondialisme vous avez je
précise aussi 1.7 milliard de personnes
dans le monde qui sont totalement
exclues du système bancaire qui sont
dépendantes des transferts que leurs
familles font depuis les pays acp vers
des pib mais au-delà de ces transferts
qui ont aussi besoin d'accès au capital
qui ont su besoins d'accès à des
services monétaires puisque c'est bien
de profiter des services de l'internet
nous avons 90 millions d'entreprises qui
utilisent notre service et à partir de
là si elle souhaite vendre ou acheter ou
enfin utiliser de l'argent elles ont
parfois des difficultés et donc le
cheminement c'était de dire que la
technologie blog shane combiné à
d'autres technologies en partenariat
avec d'autres entreprises parce que je
tiens à rappeler immédiatement que ce
n'est pas la monnaie de facebook c'est
la monnaie de cette organisation qui
aujourd'hui comporte 27 membres qui
avait évidemment vocation à à s'agrandir
on peut citer hubert on peut citer visa
mais on peut citer il y a puisque nous
sommes ici en france donc des
partenaires de tous bords et de toutes
deux tout diversité l'association libre
à est une association indépendante au
sein de laquelle facebook
à une voix parmi d'autres elle est
installée en suisse pour les raisons
expliquées par monsieur markus pour des
raisons aussi réglementaire et qui sera
supervisée à cet endroit et la libre à
et est assise sur une réserve libra et
s'est réservé composée de modèles vous
connaissez bien évidemment le dollar
l'euro le yen la livre sterling donc des
monnaies étatique est censée mener
étatique
il n'y a pas de libre a donc il faut
vraiment être très clair sur le fait
qu'on ait en rien dans une substitution
de l'état on est dans un service qui va
être proposée qui fonctionnera au sein
je dirais de l'écosystème et du réseau
libre à et qui apportera les vrais
facilité pour des millions de personnes
dans le monde
pour ce qui est des questions de
sécurité que vous avez mentionné il y a
de toute façon aujourd'hui un énorme
problème d'argent noir la crypto monnaie
n'est pas nouvelle le bitcoin existe
depuis plusieurs années il est utilisé
sur le dark web il est utilisé à des
fins diverses et variées pour des bonnes
raisons pour des mauvaises raisons là
c'est l'opportunité d'avoir un service
je veux dire avec des grandes
entreprises connues qu'ils soient
américaines européennes et c'est qu'ils
utilisent la blog shane c'est à dire une
technologie qui n'oublie pas c'est à
dire que c'est traçable on ne peut pas
effacer une transaction viala blocs
chaîne donc on est en pleine
transparence et donc cela apporte des
vraies garanties
contrairement à des paiements en cash ou
via d'autres types de services
numériques pour le coup intraçable enfin
pour ce qui est des données personnelles
là aussi je veux vous rassurer
ce sont deux choses complètement séparés
il n'est en rien question de voir
fusionner des méga base de données de
contenu entre votre activité libre à et
votre activité sur facebook pour le
service tout cas que nous fournirons
puisqu'il aura d'autres services qui
seront basés sur la libre à veut la part
des autres partenaires et je voudrais
aussi dire une chose c'est le début on
fait pas les choses en se cachant là on
l'annoncé on a annoncé les partenaires
on va rencontrer des régulateurs des
banques centrales des gouvernements il
ya des missions le g7 s'est saisi du
dossier
il s'agit pas que vous vous réveillez un
matin avec soudainement la libre à qui
s'échangent sur des téléphones
on est loin de ça
parce qu'on veut le faire d'une façon
que ce soit possible le jour où on ne
dira ok vous pouvez le faire n'est pas
question de le faire avant de le faire
sauvagement bien au contraire
voilà il faut entrer dans une culture de
régulation extrêmement forte secteur
bancaire très régulée la fine taquet
réguler voilà il n'y a aucune raison
pour que nous suivions passé régulation
mais j'insiste sur le fait que
l'émergence de d'un service de cryptes
monnaie stable global régulé avec des
entreprises connues peut apporter un
vrai bénéfice pour ce qui est des
contenus facebook vous l'avez mentionné
la tribune de mark zuckerberg monsieur
le président a une position très claire
sur le sujet si on devait refaire les
règles l'internet
aujourd'hui les pouvoirs publics je
pense aurait une approche très
différente
la question des contenus
elle se pose de façon vous avez les
règles du service et vous avez les lois
évidemment que les lois sont supérieures
de règles du service
elles sont d'ailleurs dans les pays
démocratiques l'expression de la volonté
générale puisqu'on parle de souveraineté
ici donc en aucun cas il s'agirait
d'avoir des règles du service supérieure
aux lois locales
d'ailleurs nous avons participé à une
mission conduite par monsieur loutrel et
avec l'initiative derrière président de
la république et du gouvernement
français visant à ouvrir les portes et
les fenêtres de facebook pour montrer
tout ce que nous faisons en matière de
modération et analyser ce qui pourrait
être amélioré le rapport de monsieur
loutrel et de son équipe rendue au mois
de mai donnent beaucoup de pistes en la
matière il ya aussi par ailleurs la
proposition de loi de mme adama via qui
a été voté en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale et qui vient aussi
renforcer la responsabilité des plates
formes en la matière il dont acte et oui
nous respecteront la loi et en aucun cas
ce projet de deux comités de supervision
vient remettre cela en cause mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ce comité de
supervision alors je l'appelle comme ça
parce que ne voyait pas une malice
vis-à-vis de mon président et fondateur
mark zuckerberg il a décidé de l'appeler
cour suprême je pense pour imager ce
dont il s'agit pour imager
la solution à un problème qui nous a été
régulièrement soulevée non seulement par
les pouvoirs publics mais aussi par des
acteurs associatifs et les experts il
comment se fait-il
la question qui lui était posée que sur
les sujets de contenu qui dépendent des
règles votre service je parle pas de la
loi là c'est un problème légal vous
admirons des tribunaux et facebook est
soumis bien sûr aux tribunaux que pour
savoir si sur vos standards dits de la
communauté je suis en désaccord avec
vous qu'est ce qui se passe donc je fais
un premier appel une fois vous avez
supprimé mon contenu etc
mais quand son sait-il que sur les cas
les plus compliqués ce soit mark
zuckerberg qui décide de cela et c'est
le cas aujourd'hui
quand il ya un cas très compliqué ça ça
pouvait remonter jusqu'à son bureau bon
chacun peut comprendre que transférer la
décision d'un seul homme
un groupe de personnes à peu près 40
d'un seul homme installé aux états unis
à un groupe d'experts internationaux
c'est objectivement un progrès c'est
quelque chose qui est actuellement en
cours de définition
on a organisé à peu près fois que je
précise les chiffres mais plusieurs
dizaines de réunions dans plusieurs pays
donc à une fois de plus qu'on ne se
cache pas on la présentait des
associations françaises on la présentait
à des experts français
on l'avait présenté au groupe de
monsieur loutrel pour qu'on ait des
retours et on a déjà eu des retours
constructive certains je dirais francs
mais c'est nécessaire pour être sûr que
quand ce comité existera il sera en
capacité de fonctionner normalement mais
là une fois de plus bon l'image pour
suprême peut interpeller mais quand je
vous explique de son qu'il s'agit on
voit bien que c'est quelque chose qui
est propre service qui est propre règle
du service qui mis en place par le
service lui-même pour régler ses propres
questions internes et qui en aucun cas
va venir en contradiction avec la cour
de cassation le conseil d'état la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme etc etc
sûrement pas voilà je voulais être là
que j'ai été un peu long mais je voulais
remercier quoi on va donner la parole à
monsieur leur apportera tout cas
stéphane authier mort qu'il représente
pour nous rejoindre
un petit peu de retard on y lit merci
monsieur président effectivement je lui
plais pour quelques instants gérard
longuet qui va nous rejoindre pour
poursuivre les propos du président
j'aurais de deux premières questions
relatives aux données
effectivement comme vous l'avez signalé
tout à l'heure je veux mentionner le
cloud act qui permet aux autorités
américaines de stocker des données
quelle que soit sa de disposer des
données quel que soit le lieu de
stockage plus exactement c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui interroge
qui inquiètent légitimement en
particulier les pouvoirs publics
français puisque c'est autant des
données personnelles particulier que des
données qui peuvent être stratégique des
entreprises françaises qui pourraient
être ainsi qu'ils pourraient voir leurs
données pillées facebook facebook ou le
lait dit tout à l'heure ses 36 millions
d'utilisateurs réguliers par mois donc
c'est évidemment massif donc de question
pouvez-vous nous nous assurer que
facebook ne permet ni ne permettra aux
autorités américaines de prendre
connaissance des données de nos
concitoyens français
et puis deuxième question comment
comptez vous concilier ses obligations
avec les les règles européennes de
protection des données à savoir le hergé
alors ma compréhension du clad
acte c'est qu'il est venu comme une
réponse à un problème juridique qui est
que le m l'at on pour l'acronyme jeu
mathieu ligoule assistant tweetie qui
permet la coopération judiciaire
internationale a été créée une époque où
le numérique n'existait pas vous voulez
d'élèves apparemment de il s'agit de
faire des demandes de données entre
les deux rives de l'atlantique pouvait
prendre plusieurs mois
je ma compréhension du cloud c'est que
ça sa génèse a été créé pour justement
permettre de régler les difficultés
qu'ils ont à voir avec le m lattes le
cloud à que c'est il faut être aussi
précis sur cela c'est ce sont des
demandes judiciaires c'est un juge
américain s'est passé pas il y avait pu
avoir des histoires dans le passé
c'est en aucun cas une backdoor ou je ne
sais quel accès généralisé indifférence
il ya des données c'est ça reste sous la
protection du quatrième amendement de la
constitution américaine
donc il ya il ya des garanties qui sont
apportés par l'état de droit américain
sur ce point par ailleurs l'europe
elle-même se dote d'un instrument
juridique comparables qui est le
règlement européen ces règlements je
crois que l'on directives mais bon peu
importe si évidente
et est-ce qu'il ya aussi dans le cloud
accès l'idée d'accords spéciaux qui
peuvent être conclu entre les autorités
américaines et l'autorité d'un pays x ou
y
pour faciliter ces échanges bilatéraux
et réciproque de données aujourd'hui je
crois que le royaume uni à un tel accord
avec les états unis
des discussions sont toujours en cours
au niveau européen
pour ce qui est des autres états membres
de l'union européenne est le premier jeu
des commentaires que j'aurai affaire
c'est que pour nous en tant
qu'entreprise vous lis tout alors
installé sur laon plusieurs états
évidemment on est respectueux des lois
locales on ne veut pas pour autant le
faire dans une situation de conflit de
droits dans des situations qui portrait
difficultés en la matière donc on ne
peut qu'encourager des processus
internationaux de ce genre et européens
pour qu'un nouveau parapluie juridique
en vain
nouvelle architecture juridique plus tôt
soit mise en place pour régler ces
problèmes parce que c'est pas vraiment à
nous de les régler parce qu'on est par
ailleurs constamment sollicité pour être
plus dans la collaboration c'est ce que
nous faisons pour donner des données des
enquêtes c'est ce que nous faisons
évidemment il ya eu des annonces en la
matière récemment mais dans le fond il
faut que les états puissent être en
situation de régler ses difficultés donc
je pense que la réponse à votre question
c'est de dire ces dispositifs existent
on veut les appliquer avec la plus
grande je dirais le plus grand sérieux
possible et on veut être évidemment en
respect avec le rg on va pas venir en
contradiction du rejet pdc quand même
une régulation extrêmement forte avec
des sanctions extrêmement dissuasif donc
aussi bien pour la confiance des
utilisateurs que même d'un point de vue
purement légale et politique
on n'aurait aucun intérêt à le faire
voilà mais je rappelle il est parfois un
petit peu gênant que les entreprises
soient mis dans des situations de
conflit juridique merci madame catherine
morin desailly président de la
commission de la culture du sénat
merci monsieur le président bon moi je
voulais aller droit au but
peut-on encore faire confiance à
facebook sachant que mark zuckerberg n'a
pas dit la vérité devant le congrès
américain
puisqu'en novembre dernier donc date qui
a suivi cette audition le new york times
a révélé que finalement facebook était
bien au courant de l'infiltration des
russes sur les réseaux depuis 2014
pourquoi le boat qui étaient alertés n'a
pas pris toutes les mesures utiles pour
faire remonter l'information vers les
états concernés
du coup quelles sont les mesures
aujourd'hui mise en place par facebook
pour empêcher ce genre de cyber-attaques
en quelque sorte ou de cyber préemption
du réseau social qui doit être partagé
et neutre quelles sont les mesures qui
ont été aujourd'hui
prise prises en compte
deuxième question pourquoi monsieur
zuckerberg n'accepte que jamais de se
rendre aux convocations parce que ce
sont des convocations cantat parlement
demande des comptes
comme nous en demandons aujourd'hui
c'est une commission denquête pourquoi
monsieur recours bas ne s'est il pas
rendu à londres à l'invitation de 11
parlement à travers le monde ce qui
représente quand même une surface
importante de nombre d'utilisateurs de
de facebook pour justement venir
expliquer ce qui s'était passé avec la
sphère cambridge america vous mesurez
l'inquiétude très forte des politiques
sur le sur le sur le sujet question me
subsidiaire comment travaillez vous
aujourd'hui et avec quelle entreprise de
l'agrégation de données dont des
agrégateurs de données travaillez vous
aujourd'hui est ce que la décision
allemande assez ferme qui était de 2
vous vous enjoindre ne plus collecter
des données et surtout de les agréger
selon des techniques propres à ces
entreprises pour tel ou tel objectif
comment comptez vous appliquer cette
mesure je trouve qui est une bonne
mesure de manière plus large pour
retrouver la confiance de deux de
l'utilisateur et puis dernière question
aux états unis des voix se font entendre
pas seulement la voix de deux
parlementaires mais également
d'ingénieurs y compris le qte qui confie
au fondateur de facebook qui eux
plaident pour
segmentation de l'entreprise et un
démantèlement c'est qu'aujourd'hui watsa
benz ta g sont corrélées à à facebook
que répondez-vous aux états unis à
cesser et ses idées qui circulent et ne
serait-ce pas non plus une façon de
retrouver davantage la confiance de
l'utilisateur merci monsieur vote estime
hockey vous me permettrez de prendre un
certain temps pour répondre à ces
différentes questions
écoutez on a je dirais aucun intérêt à
agir d'une façon à ce que vont perdre la
confiance des utilisateurs ce qu'on leur
trouve pas il n'y a pas de compagnies
aériennes ne sont pas s'agir d'une cape
ann facebook 100 utilisateurs tout
s'arrête donc le point que vous avez
mentionné vous aurez pu mentionner
d'autres sont pris avec sérieux et je
vais décrire ce qui a été ce qui a été
fait depuis ces dernières années
la question n'est pas de savoir si on
fait des erreurs c'est mark zuckerberg
lundi devant le congrès des erreurs ont
été faites mais des compagnies aériennes
connaissent des tragédies et sans relève
très bien parce qu'elles font ce qu'il
ya à faire le rio paris c'était il ya
dix ans et je suis j'ai toute confiance
en la france et la compagnie que je
préfère bon tout ça pour dire la
question de l'entreprise aujourd'hui
c'était dans la vie des entreprises
c'est ça c'est de se dire il ya des
erreurs des crises graves des choses qui
entame vraiment la confiance
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors je veux
répondre à vos questions je commenterai
pas l'article du new york times a voulu
vous le comprendrez
je vous laisse aussi à vos commentaires
sur le fait qu'il aurait menti ou pas
mais je vais rentrer un peu plus dans le
vif du sujet en 2016
l'élection en tout cas américaine a
montré à quel point les outils qu'ils
avaient était pas conçu avec eux avec
une vocation disons vie à être détournés
plutôt de manière électorale on s'est
rendu compte que c'était possible
voilà le admis l'erreur est ce qui
compte c'est qu'est ce qu'on a fait
depuis qu'est ce qu'on a fait depuis
vous avez des équipes qui ont été mises
en place il travaille à temps plein
si notamment le travail d'un de mes
collègues monsieur blecher sur tout ce
qui concerne les menaces et
régulièrement son équipe détecte des
réseaux ou des comportements de
manipulation que ce soit en période
électorale ou hors période électorale
ils font tomber les pages en la matière
tout ce que nous faisons en la matière
est extrêmement transparent et
d'ailleurs nous avons aussi rencontré
les autorités françaises compétentes en
la matière pour les informer il ya aussi
tout ce qu'on a mis en place pour les
élections ce qui a été révélé au moment
de l'élection de 2016 c'est que
publicité alors aux etats-unis le
contexte la publicité politique est
différent vous savez mon tout cas les
publicités sur un réseau social pouvait
être utilisée pour cibler des personnes
avec des publicités des thématiques
d'intérêt général visant éventuellement
à orienter leurs leurs convictions
politiques
là encore nous avions mis en place une
archive avec des mesures de transparence
il faut que toutes ces publicités
l'argent qui est dépensé et l'identité
l'émetteur des civils publicité est
désormais connue donc c'est un phénomène
vampire c'est à dire que quand je me
mettais de la lumière sur quelque chose
soudainement on peut espérer que ces
comportements sur extrêmement limité
voire s'arrête
d'ailleurs on ne peut que saluer le fait
que la france ait repris ce type
d'initiative en les renforçant via la
loi sur la manipulation de l'information
qui avait été examinée je crois à
l'assemblée nationale je crois pas me
rappeler ici d'ailleurs en la matière et
qui ont repris ces dispositions pour la
france et facebook a ensuite mis en
place pour les élections européennes
les mêmes dispositions à l'échelle de
l'union européenne en l'absence
d'ailleurs je tiens le signal et d'une
réglementation européenne harmonisée en
la matière donc il a fallu qu'on fasse
aussi des décisions en tant
qu'entreprise privée qui pouvait
peut-être relever de la sphère publique
on peut
je crois que là aussi qu invité les
pouvoirs publics européens à régler ces
questions comme l'ont fait récemment de
mark zuckerberg et monsieur clegg
je pourrais être un peu plus long mais
voilà les mesures principales en matière
de manipulation dit manipulation de nos
réseaux par ailleurs on agit massivement
matière de fake news on a des
partenariats avec des failles shaker
avec le monde la lfp pour en citer
qu'eux donc on a pris extrêmement au
sérieux tout cela maintenant est-ce que
ça empêchera pour toujours ces
phénomènes d'arrivée sa personne n'a de
boule de cristal pour le dire mais ce
qu'on fait tout notre possible pour que
ça n'arrive pas oui parce que le
problème est réel et vous pouvez en tout
cas compter sur notre collaboration pour
y arriver
votre deuxième point sur mark zuckerberg
et sa convocation bon alors il s'est
exprimé dans le congrès américain mais
quand même pas oublier qui s'est exprimé
devant le parlement repères je crois la
même année et je crois que le parlement
européen
les anglaises une rhétorique en
excusez-moi de vous interrompre
mais la réunion à laquelle je fais
référence jaussaud de regrouper des pays
qui ne
sont ni les états unis ni des membres de
l'union européenne
voilà en tout cas je tiens à signaler le
fait qu' il a eu aucune difficulté à
s'exprimer devant le parlement européen
est un parlement qui représente 400
millions d'individus en europe donc il
ya toute légitimité qui est élu au
suffrage universel direct
il a répondu à toutes les questions tous
les groupes politiques ont eu l'occasion
de l'interroger sur ces sujets il l'a
fait très volontiers
ça s'est passé et je tiens à rappeler
que ça s'est fait de manière tout à fait
collaborative
non je ne suis pas ici en capacité de
vous dire à sa place pourquoi il prend
une décision
x ou y quand il s'agit de s'exprimer
dans c dans ses différentes institutions
en tout cas pour ce qui est de l'union
européenne
cela a été fait au sein du parlement
européen l'année dernière je crois que
personne ne peut douter ici de
légitimité de ce parlement élu par 400
millions de personnes pour ce qui est de
l'allemagne
vous permettra ici de dire en toute
sincérité que je suis pas informé des
détails de cette affaire puisque je suis
responsable des affaires publiques pour
la france d'ailleurs c'est un peu pour
cela que j'avais demandé que quelques
questions ne soient communiqués en
avance parce que vous remarquerez
qu'elle est assez technique assez
précise mais ce qu'on peut faire si vous
ne s'agit pas de se dérober ici
évidemment c'est qu'on est un petit
suivi
j'imagine que cela est possible après
cet entretien pour qu'on vous communique
vos questions sur les agrégateurs de
données et peut-être ne répond plus
largement sur ce sur ce cas en
particulier pour ce qui est de deux
seins des fesses b'hook en plusieurs
entités bon là encore je pense que je
vais faire une réponse qui sera assez
proche de ce qu'a dit monsieur clegg
dans son dans sa tribune sur le sujet et
qui est qu'elles sont cherche à faire
pourquoi été construit le droit de la
concurrence
il a été il a été construit pour éviter
des abus notamment sur les prix donc
pour permettre aux consommateurs d'avoir
accès toujours à une offre
diverses et à bas coût si on regarde le
secteur du numérique aujourd'hui il faut
pas considérer facebook comme une entité
monolithique en matière de messagerie
nous ne sommes pas numéro 1 en matière
de places de marché market place nous ne
sommes pas numéro un look il ya des
secteurs d'activité de facebook qui
existent en matière de vidéo nous ne
sommes pas numéro 1 mais je veux dire
donc il ya des secteurs sur lequel vous
preniez dire vous êtes numéro un on va
dire c'est le l'activité principale de
réseau social avec les éléments que j'ai
donnée mais sur d'autres types
d'activités qui sont aujourd'hui en
croissance extrêmement rapide
imessage d'autres services de messagerie
chinois etc etc sont en avance sur
facebook donc quand on parle déjà de
concurrence il faut regarder un peu le
périmètre de cette concurrence
deuxièmement il y a une vraie aussi
question qui se pose que le droit de la
concurrence n'a pas été non plus conçus
pour quelque part sanctionner le succès
car si vous avez le droit d'avoir du
succès la question c'est qu'est ce que
vous en faites
et est ce que c'est la bonne réponse
après ou à divers points que vous
soulevez parmi les points qui sont
soulevées les points de confiance les
points de régulation des contenus et
cetera est ce que aujourd'hui avoir
facebook qui fait bouillir 2 milliards
et demi de personnes vous avez instagram
qui fait un milliard de personnes
what's up c'est un milliard de personnes
même si vous coupez ses services les
questions que vous soulevez à juste
titre de manipulation de l'information
de discours haineux etc
est-ce que ça va se régler soudainement
alors que vous aurez encore des gros
blocs d'un milliard de personnes
les problèmes restent les mêmes
simplement il se diversifie donc ce que
je veux dire par là c'est pas que le
droit de la concurrence n'est pas la
réponse à tous les problèmes de sûreté
ou de politique que pose ce type
d'intégration
merci oui on peut dire aussi que si ces
groupes était séparé il ya une forme
d'émulation et notamment dans un service
apporté à l'utilisateur qui serait de
créer les conditions de la confiance
déjà bon la façon dont vous nous
répondez
et toujours la même c'est à dire que
faute de réglementation vous renvoyer la
responsabilité aux politiques et
finalement les usages vont envoyer
toujours vers les utilisateurs
on voit bien que c'est quand même
toujours contraint et forcé que vous
finissez par adopter certaines mesures
d'autorégulation plus ou moins consentis
pour essayer de retrouver la confiance
des utilisateurs moi je pense qu'il faut
agir de façon beaucoup plus structurelle
et puis c'est assez étonnant vu la
gravité des sujets d'ailleurs mon
homologue britannique damian collins à
la chambre des communes dans son rapport
n'hésite pas à vous traitez de gangsters
c'est quand même très étonnant que vous
ne travaillez pas en europe pour
retrouver la confiance des européens que
vous ne travaillez pas avec votre
homologue allemand et que vous ne soyez
pas au courant de la législation du ce
qui se passe au niveau de la régulation
pour facebook
en allemagne je suis assez surprise
qu'une société de votre puissance ne
soit pas plus stratégique et collectives
n'auront là ces questions qui sont
d'ordre d'ordre mondial en tout cas
j'aimerais mieux battesti la même
manière que j'aurais bien aimé avoir une
réponse à mon courrier du 13 mars
2010neuf lequel qui vous étaient
adressées pour lequel j'ai jamais eu de
réponse en tout cas je vous en remercie
madame je veux les i monsieur je je je
vais bien je me permets d'être
respectueusement des accords avec sony
d'exprimer je travaille en étroite
collaboration avec bien sûr mes
collègues allemands et de l'ensemble de
l'union européenne et au delà dans le
monde nous avons des outils
technologiques qui le permettent mais
vous m'avez dit je suis sous serment
je ne veux pas ici à portée de frau qui
serait inexacts ou incomplets
donc je me suis engagé devant voit
répondre après coup et oui j'assume le
fait de pas toujours être au courant de
tous les détails de tous les litiges
juridiques qui se produisent au delà de
la france donc si j'avais été pris en
défaut sur la france j'ai envie de dire
toucher ça arrive dans un autre pays bon
voilà c'est comme ça
mais en tout cas on va on va vous
répondre sur ce point pour ce qui est de
votre courrier écoutez je suis navré
pouvez vous me rappelez le sujet parce
que je
il peut connaissance je peux pas blâmer
ici quelconque aulaye du service du
courrier
mais bon je crois que vous avez mes
coordonnées email et téléphoniques la
plus de temps voilà en tout cas je pense
que je ne me cache pas et on sait déjà
rencontré donc ya pas troubles merci
monsieur le rapporteur jeu en langues
oui je voulais d'abord vous priés
d'accepter mes excuses je présidais
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques et
nous avions un rapport de l'excellent
député didier baichère cher catherine
sur la reconnaissance faciale qui es tu
un des aspects de la souveraineté
numérique sur lequel notre commission se
penche
moi je voudrais romieu sur échec nous
avons évoqué hier avec l'industriel et
qui nous a indiqué que vous étiez vous
facebook l'un des principaux
investisseurs actuellement dans les
câbles sous marins et je souhaitais
comprendre dans quel esprit facebook
intervient puisqu'au fond le système des
grands opérateurs du numérique a
consisté à utiliser des réseaux
existants jusqu'à présent des réseaux
qui sont terrestres et quel est
l'objectif de cette très forte
implication dans un maillage de grands
datacenters datacenter par des réseaux
sous-marins scud un manque de confiance
sur les opérateurs ou l'insuffisance des
opérateurs actuels alors là aussi je
serai présent dans ma réponse c'est pas
forcément des dossiers que sur lesquels
je suis informé manière générale mais
pas dans les détails mais on pourra
poursuivre ma compréhension de ce type 2
deux problématiques d'ailleurs c'est
comme les investissements dans les data
center c'est l'investissement
technologique qui permet finalement à
ses services de fonctionner je dirais de
manière toujours plus rapides et plus
près de l'utilisateur
je sais que nous avons des partenariats
notamment avec orange pour certains
endroits le déploiement de ces câbles là
mais je préfère me taire non pas pour ne
pas vous répondre
simplement je n'ai pas les détails de
ces projets industriels chance qu'ils
cessent pas grave parce que mais en tout
cas c'est vraiment une balance oui bien
sûr communique pas que ce soit seulement
note d'orientation dans quel esprit
europe au plan mondial devient
investisseurs et donc et en particulier
qu'elle sera l'ouverture de deux de ses
réseaux à d'autres utilisateurs
ma compréhension sait que ça se fait
souvent je compatis avec d'autres
opérateurs aussi parce que la
mutualisation sur des coups aussi
important est certainement le le choix
le plus rationnel mêlant quand je
reviendrai vers vous alors sur le sujet
beaucoup plus terre-à-terre et beaucoup
plus nationale
facebook s'est illustré par par retirer
rapidement le tableau de l'origine du
monde de courbet vous en avez parler
peut-être en mon absence
alors il se trouve que le président de
la république est allé à ornans ou va y
aller d'ailleurs je crois
il se trouve que mon excellent camarade
député hervé novelli et président des
amis de courbet on est très malheureux
de penser que sur les pratiques de de
contrebande facebook est quand même
assez détendu mais sur une oeuvre d'art
je dois reconnaître qui est assez direct
d'ailleurs tout le problème est de
savoir quelle tête correspond à cette
partie du corps mais enfin c'est un
autre débat
peu de jeunes on a traversé laquelle les
centres de gravité culturel de facebook
mais répondre immédiatement bons jeux
jeux permettrait de relever la votre mac
ces produits contenant de jeu quand même
voilà dire qu'on n'est sûrement pas
relax sur ces sujets même si
voilà il peut toujours y avoir des
problèmes mais je vais répondre sur le
fond moment là j'avais pas vous posez
pas la question mais finalement je
gravis ghoul a posé ce que j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur ça et j'ai même rencontré
le plaignant et on a beaucoup parlé de
ces sujets donc il ya un plaignant à
l'origine oui enfin c'est une affaire
très médiatisée donc voilà on va pas
parce qu'elle a valeur de principe
ciblées sur un aspect de de censure non
mais alors je vais vous répondre
c'est un tableau qui est autorisé voilà
la question qui occupe
si vous parlez de la sphère du rang
c'était pour et d'ailleurs les tribunaux
nous ont donné raison il disait que
c'était parce qu'on avait retiré ce
tableau ce qui n'avait pas été établies
les bunyetes un événement bon c'est
devenu un événement mais en fait la cour
nous a donné raison mais je vais
m'expliquer sur la politique de contenus
font c'est ça qui nous intéresse c'est
c'est la peinture de nu est parfaitement
autorisé
voilà vous avez dit à juste titre ce
tableau était assez réaliste on peut
rendre hommage à l'artiste sinequa
techniquement sur les standards de
l'époque mais en tout cas pour dire qu'
il est autorisé et qu'il y ait eu des
erreurs de modération sur le logis du
monde probablement mais le fait qu'ils
aient eu des erreurs de modération ne
veut pas dire qu'il n'est pas autorisé
il est parfaitement autorisé l'équipe de
modération sur visualiser sa presse
c'est quoi je vais il répond je veux
juste préciser sur la nudité parce que
je sais qu'on nous dit parfois mais vous
êtes américains puritains ya pas de
nudité autorisé que c'est un bon aura
tendance à vous dire voilà on a tendance
à le lire pour vous parler de centralité
culturel je vais deviner ce point bon il
ya quantité de contenus qui sont tout à
fait autorisé
la nuit dit artistique en fait partie et
c'est bon ce qui n'est pas autorisé
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de bonnes
raisons pour ne pas le faire je sais la
nudité photo la nudité photo tout
simplement parce qu'à l'échelle qui est
la nôtre si nous ouvrions plus les
portes à ce type de nudité on serait je
sais qu'il ya une mobilisation soit en
du gouvernement sur la question de
l'accès à la pornographie par des
démineurs
vous imaginez bien qu'on aura des vraies
difficultés et par ailleurs vous avez
aussi des adolescents qui sont victimes
de ce qu'on appelle de revenge porn
c'est à dire des photos d'eux-mêmes qui
circule sur les réseaux
à partir du moment où vous n'autorisez
pas la nudité vous avez une arme assez
tranchées assez forte qui empêche ce
type de photos de circuler alors me
direz-vous mais quid de la photo d'art
bon c'est une difficulté aujourd'hui qui
n'est pas résolu
il faut l'assumer je pense nous empêche
pas la voir des photos suggestives des
photos proche de la nudité mais ça pose
des problèmes sur des vraies photos de
nu dont acte
mais je voudrais qu'on comprenne toutes
les bonnes raisons pour lesquelles la
nudité peut être interdite sur notre
service la question des modérateurs
on investit massivement on a à peu près
trente mille personnes dans le monde
on avait ce style on a investi des
milliards d'euros dans ces domaines on
investit aujourd'hui autant que pouvait
l'être je crois le capitalisation de
facebook au moment de son entrée en
bourse enfin j'veux plus les données
financières mais c'est tout à fait
considérable et l'air ça répond aussi à
la partie de la mutualisation serre que
vous quand vous avez plusieurs réseaux
sociaux vous pouvez mutualisé aussi les
questions de sûreté en back office
donc on a à peu près trente mille
personnes qui couvrent h 24 7 jours sur
7 et une centaine de langues
les questions de contenu sur la
plateforme 85 % des utilisateurs ne sont
pas américains
donc ce serait une erreur presque une
faute en fait combien 4 85% de copier
coller un modèle au reste du monde
bon la politique de contenu de facebook
cette politique qui s'inspire des grands
principes je dirais de démocratie
libérale la liberté le principe la
restriction d'exception il faut balancer
la liberté la sécurité la liberté la
responsabilité c'est ce que nous voulons
faire beau modérateurs sont répartis
dans le monde
oui vous voyez en europe le monde a fait
un article très fouillé sur marche de
leur exemple dublin va de différents
types de modération moi même temps à
paris je suis impliqué sur des décisions
de contenu voilà c'est une équipe
globale de sûreté on va dire qu'il fera
que de la modération soulève aussi des
experts on a des gens qui font que du
terrorisme et un jeune 4 etc etc
comment vivez-vous dernière question ici
que l'interop l'interopérabilité oui
alors effectivement aujourd'hui le rg
pour reprendre une réglementation qui
traite de ces sujets donne le droit à
l'utilisateur et c'est tout à fait
normal de télécharger ces données de
manière simple et dans des formats
ouverts et standardisée j'ai plus le
wording exact donc ça c'est la première
étape quelque part de la portabilité
c'est à dire je récupère ce qui
m'appartient
la deuxième étape de la portabilité
c'est oui mais qu'est ce que je fais
après est-ce que c'est facile pour moi
de les prendre le mettre ailleurs
donc là on a une initiative je dirais
industriel qui a été construite avec
microsoft twitter ou google lido tu puis
la liste en tête qui s'appelle le data
transfer project cordon pour l'acronyme
anglais qui vise à essayer de voir
ensemble qu'est ce qu'on peut construire
comme mécanismes techniques qui vous
permettrait en claquant des doigts ou
pas ou presque de transférer vos photos
de l'un vers l'autre vos données de l'un
vers l'autre etc
et d'ailleurs monsieur clegg l'avait
rappelé c'est aussi une réponse à des
questions de concurrence
si vous pouvez facilement partir d'un
réseau est allé sur l'autre parce que
vous auriez perdu la confiance ça peut
se faire très facilement
donc on travaille sur ça les réponses
sont pas pratiques parce que vous avez
des enjeux de vie privée certes moi j'ai
mes données facebook peuvent
éventuellement impliqués d'autres
personnes qui étaient ok dans la sphère
facebook est ce qu'elle serait ok que
les transferts vannes oc etc etc
donc il faut faire tout ça avec grande
prudence et parcimonie mais en tout cas
on le fait ça s'appelle le data transfer
projets que vous pouvez le voir sur
internet je vous enverrai les éléments
mais ça existe et c'est en cours de
développement tout à fait et c'est pour
les au delà de ce que la réglementation
nous
nous demande de faire pire ouzoulias
merci monsieur le président bonjour
bonjour nos aïeux juste un petit point à
propos de votre réponse à ma collègue
j'aimerais vous dire que le le suffrage
universel indirect aussi donnent de la
légitimité parce qu'en tant j'ai fait le
droit constitutionnel au jour en excuses
nous nous y sommes attachés ici non non
mais c'est juste une boutade pour
commencer moi j'avais deux questions
simples enfin une simple et l'autre un
peu plus compliqué vous avez ouvert un
laboratoire d'intelligence artificielle
à paris qui quillan qui a recruté
beaucoup de chercheurs du cnrs est de et
de l'inria
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut savoir
quelle est la rémunération moyenne
annuelle que voulant renverser
je vous promets je suis pas du tout
informé du montant de salaire de mes
collègues je pense qu'il faut être
extrêmement attractive dans des domaines
aussi compétitif ça c'est sûr parce que
c'est le tout le monde veut faire son
labo tout le monde veut les meilleurs
donc j'imagine que c'est assez attractif
mais je vous promets je n'ai aucune
information la matière autre autre
question votre société a mis à profit
très justement ce n'est pas un reproche
un internet libre qui qui en grande
partie parce qu'il avait peu de peu de
règles d'organisation vous a permis
l'expansion que vous nous décrivez
aujourd'hui le risque serait que
la part laissée à cette liberté absolue
presque absolu se réduisent et que
finalement les règles d'autorégulation
dont vous nous dites que aujourd'hui
elles sont pour vous un objectif
politique
elles finissent par réagir la totalité
de l'internet libre qui ne le serait
plus est qui et qui vous placerait
finalement en situation de régulateur
absolu de tout l'internet
alors quelle quelle mesure vous prenez
pour conserver encore l'esprit initial
de l'internet et préserver cette liberté
dont on dont on a besoin aussi
alors effectivement là on est un peu à
la croisée des chemins c'est à dire
qu'il ya une phase d'expansion
je me souviens de l'époque où j'utilise
netscape sur windows 98 tu pourras aller
surya de maintenant ça n'a rien à voir
donc il ya constamment des nouveaux
produits je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
n'est pas non plus dans une phase de
figer quand on voit l'émergence d'un
réseau social comme tik tok
si vous parlez à des adolescents autour
de vous leur dites facebook ou tik tok
jeu assez convaincu qu'il risque de dire
j'utilise n'en est pas l'auteur utilise
instagram
je suis en train de dire capables
adolescents sur facebook je pense que là
bien au contraire le service reste
stable et en croissance mais ce que j'ai
a pas là il ya une diversification des
usages notamment auprès des jeunes qui
est totalement fulgurante et donc je
pense que on peut encore avoir confiance
dans l'idée qu'il ya des nouveaux
produits qui arrivent et qui nécessitait
pour ce qu'il est ce que je comprends
votre question c'est est-ce qu'à un
moment donné on arrive à une phase
aujourd'hui pour vous plus installer de
l'internet plus institutionnelle plus
régulé est-ce que ça va pas finalement
installé des acteurs dans leur situation
c'est toujours la question des barrières
à l'entrée
mais là je pense qu'il faut résoudre une
petite contradiction c'est à dire que il
nous est demandé à juste titre d'avoir
plus de responsabilités responsabilité
elle est
et pas que les galets l'éthique et les
politiques les morales veut dire mais un
des éléments de sa responsabilité c'est
la croissance était légale c'est à dire
quel type de sanctions vous risquez si
vous ne faites pas x ou y actions bon on
est clairement dans cette avec les
données personnelles on a eu l'heur gpd
sur les contenus on y va enfin voilà il
ya de plus en plus de choses donc après
j'ai envie de dire nous et c'était le
sens une intervention de mardi au camac
et là aussi je vous pouvez penser que
c'est de la malice mais dites nous ce
que vous voulez on le fera dites-nous
l'equilibre que vous souhaitez vis-à-vis
de nous qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
nous transférer ou pas comme
responsabilités et on s'y tiendra avec
la supervision de l'autorité comme le
csa en la matière mais vous voyez bien
la difficulté quand on nous demande de
décider en 24 heures ce qui est légal ou
pas légal c'est objectivement puisqu'on
est là dans une commission qui parlent
souvent tu es un petit transfert de
souveraineté
on nous demande de faire quelque chose
qui est plutôt du ressort de l'état
quelques comment ça se passe comment
l'état va contrôler ça etc etc et par
ailleurs on dit mais vous avez trop de
pouvoir oui je la sais pas de la malice
c'est simplement ce que je constate
depuis six ans et je pense qu'il est
nécessaire pour en donner pour nous de
dire voilà dites nous ce que vous voulez
on le fera parce que je pense que c'est
la seule façon notamment dans le cadre
européen de s'en sortir
sinon il y aura toujours eu un excès de
lin ou un excès de l'autre et par
ailleurs vous pouvez aussi favoriser un
écosystème de start up en ayant des
règles adaptées plus souple et plus
flexibles les concernant j'imagine ça
c'est assez courant qu'il ya des effets
de seuil qui soit mis en place notamment
dans leur j'ai payé dans d'autres
réglementations mais attention à ce que
quand elle rattrape le seuil
voilà sl sont capables de franchir merci
je je voudrais revenir sur le projet du
libre
pourquoi devrai devrions-nous vous faire
confiance par rapport à la protection
des données
donc financières en l'occurrence dans le
cadre de ce projet au regard
voilà des échecs auxquels vous avez pu
être confrontés en matière de protection
des données pour première première
question monsieur markus nom a déjà été
cité au cours de cette audition à la
réponse concernant justement la la
protection absolue des données
financières avec le nom de transfert des
données financières de calibre à
l'associé l'association qui est en
charge du libra vers facebook
à cette question là a dit que voilà pour
le moment seulement il n'était pas
question d'envisager des transferts de
calibre avait reversé facebook sauf at
il ajouté consentement de l'usager alors
voilà tout ça
l'interrogé et interroge par rapport à
ceux à ce projet et conséquences que
cela pourrait avoir sur voilà
l'appréciation que que parfois certains
acteurs peuvent porter sur sur les
individus ça c'est ma première première
question dans quelle est votre position
par rapport à ça est ce que on peut
avoir des garanties comment comment
envisagez-vous le futur de ce projet par
rapport à cette question là et 2e
deuxième question être êtes vous a
priori favorable à une hypothèse de
régulation des plateformes de
supervision publique par l'état ou des
organisations des temps ça pourrait être
à l'échelle européenne des plateformes
pourriez vous m'indiquer sur quel type
d'activité en général les contenus les
données de manière générale après ça
peut ça peut ça finit dans la réflexion
mais voilà sur le pommeau du principe il
ya plusieurs éléments
je crois qu'il n'est pas naïf on sait
qu'il ya un vrai une pente raide en
matière de confiance qui est importante
et que lancer un tel projet nécessite
d'ailleurs de manière générale la
confiance dans les institutions
financières de la part nos concitoyens
quand même assez faible
donc facebook qui arrive en plus et
d'autres partenaires et je dirais donc
dans ces secteurs
il faut avoir conscience de ceux du
niveau de confiance que l'on a envers
soi même et par ailleurs ne le climat
général de ce secteur bon est ce que ça
veut dire que c'est impossible
non je pense qu'en plus david marcus le
dit
dix cas comme travailler sur paypal
enfin voilà qui a une vraie légitimité
en la matière qui jeu facebook depuis
longtemps il a tout à fait conscience
des difficultés de confiance que pose ce
projet la première chose c'est de
changer la méthode
en fait ce que j ai tout à l'heure si
vous vous lancez un produit et on en
discute après on nous dira mais bon vous
nous avez encore fait le coup que vous
avez lancé quelque chose on est un peu
dans cette phase de le dire est
innovante de la silicon valley qui
apportait beaucoup de choses il faut pas
non plus jeter le bébé loué en mai qui
ai dit voilà une foisonnement
d'innovations l'ours des produits puis
on voit peut-être après si ça pose des
difficultés mais là il ya un
renversement complet de la pyramide
saisir on lance rien de temps que nous a
pas dit que go et en matière de
financière le secteur que je découvre
aussi les barrières sont quand même
assez importante et à juste titre parce
que là les implications systémiques sont
considérables donc il s'agit pas de
s'amuser donc aussi bien les banques
centrales que la mf en france etc etc
donc on va faire tout ça on va avoir
beaucoup de travail
et tant mieux il y aura peut-être je
sais pas des délais ou pas j'en sais
rien en tout cas ça va se faire de façon
extrêmement sérieuse parce que comme ça
que l'on pourra pas nous croire sur
parole il faudra que ceux qui ont la
légitimité de dire ok on a parlé avec
facebook
ça peut se faire at-elle et telles
conditions et on vérifiera on va être
sur leur dos en vérifier que ça se passe
bien
bon je pense que c'est une approche qui
doit permettre normalement de restaurer
une forme de confiance pour ce qui est
de
des données je veux pas répéter ce qu'a
dit david marcus mais je pense qu'on est
là dans de toute façon dans la question
générale de donner mon banquier c'est
tout ce que j'achète
il sait tout de moi sincèrement ou est
ce que j' étais qu'est-ce que j'ai
acheté à quelle heure maintenant dans
les applications que labellisé ses
achats revient on peut tout faire et
avec l'idée aussi que ça me rends
service donc la question s'est il l'a
dit et je pense que dans le sens de sa
réponse et dire oui mais il y aura
toujours un élément qu'il faut prendre
en contre pour l'avenir c'est de dire
est ce que divers leur gpd et finalement
je fais des n'interdirait en ville dit
voilà ce que vous pouvez faire comment
vous pouvez le faire si des nouvelles
finalité se présente des nouvelles
choses se présentent que des
consentements sont là éventuellement
vous pouvez faire de nouvelles choses
mais on peut pas dire même dans l'esprit
du rgp dès que jamais jamais jamais
jamais jamais il n'y a rien qui puisse
se passer
simplement aujourd'hui on est dans des
logiques ou une fois plus je le dis avec
les logiques déclenchée par leur gpd de
responsabilisation et de sanctions
extrêmement importants tant navals
vous ne pouvez rien faire sans demander
l'autorisation régulateur donc là une
fois de plus on va rentrer vraiment dans
cette phase où de toute façon on n'a pas
le choix d'aller demander l'autorisation
avant de faire quelque chose
voilà et et je ne peux qu'inciter les
pouvoirs publics à muscler leurs
régulateurs ceci pour répondre à votre
deuxième question recruter les meilleurs
la meilleure expertise être vraiment
concurrence avec ses entreprises pour
astral attirer les nouveaux talents
parce que c'est tout à fait fondamentale
et favoriser aussi
des serviteurs de l'état peuvent se
nourrir d'une expérience privée et
rapporté aussi quelque chose qui permet
d'articuler mieux la théorie et la
pratique et qui fera aussi que quelques
pas des gens comme moi ne pourront pas
je dirais enfin ils sont toujours
suspects d'une suspicion légitime de ce
que je pourrais leur dire parce qu'ils
ont aussi été à ma place ou est ce que
je veux dire donc c'est vraiment on
rentre dans cette époque donc sur la
question de supervision des plateformes
oui c'est le sens de la tribu de mark
zuckerberg il faut une régulation
nécessaires et et complète sur des
domaines qui sont la vie démocratique
j'en a parlé des publicités politiques
tout à l'heure la question des contenus
qu'est ce qui est légal qu'est ce qui
n'est pas légal la question des
transferts de données et cetera et
cetera
voilà et on le fait d'une façon vous
dire faites le on ne va pas voilà c est
moi même je vous dire pour mon métier
c'est regarder tout à fait intéressante
parce qu'on est dans une logique de
proposition et voilà pour cette audition
qui s'est tenue dans le cadre des
travaux de la commission d' enquête sur
la souveraineté numérique qui est
présidé par le sénateur socialiste
franck montaugé qui a pour rapporteur le
sénateur l'est républicain gérard
longuet ces derniers bien multiplié les
auditions
outre facebook ils ont aussi entendu
google ou encore roy veille ou encore
amazon vous pouvez toujours voir et
revoir toutes les auditions sur notre
site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
le